new at noon today in some big news from  Cirque du Soleil the company has now  filed for bankruptcy protection this is  in response of course to the corona  virus the pandemic has forced all their  shows to close circa is entering a  purchase agreement now with investors to  help restart business and help employees  so under this proposal 15 million  dollars will be dedicated to help  terminated employees another five  million will pay outstanding payments to  artists that does include freelancers  now the Superior Court of Quebec will  review that filing tomorrow and we will  keep you updated on what happens there